[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETE LEPAGE: Welcome,
everybody.
Really awesome event today.
We're taking a behind scenes
look at Movi Kanti Revo, one
of the new Chrome experiments
that just launched yesterday.
My name's Pete LePage, I'm a
developer advocate with the
Chrome team.
And with me, we've got Aubrey
and KC from Subatomic who
built this absolutely phenomenal
experience.
Do you guys want to introduce
yourself?
AUBREY ANDERSON: Sure, my
name's Aubrey Anderson.
I'm the president
of Subatomic.
KC AUSTIN: My name
is KC Austin.
I'm one of the lead developers
on this project.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
So this launched yesterday.
This is something that has been
coming to fruition for us
for probably four or
five months now.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah,
about five months.
I'd say we started storyboarding
and concepting
probably fully five
months ago.
And then did some initial
concept work in the browser
just to make sure that all our
assumptions, or at least most
of our assumptions were
going to true.
And then we had a long period
of just asset creation where
we went out to Las Vegas and
shot the Cirque people doing
their performances on the
blue [? sight. ?]
And a lot of post production,
and just getting what they
call mats sorted out, and
getting everybody keyed.
And sort of in parallel to
that, KC and I have been
developing the browser, working
on building scenes.
And we'll kind of show you how
we build the scenes as we go.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome, cool.
So for those of you who are
watching live right now, we do
have a moderator queue, that
if you want to go post your
questions, you can go post
your questions there.
We'll take your live
questions towards
the end of our session.
So as we dive into some of these
things, please post your
questions there.
Let's jump in and talk about
some of the 3D experiences and
how those were built.
Because it's a pretty new
concept for the browser to put
all of these pieces into the
world and actually build
something that as it rotates
and moves, really the
prospective just changes.
You've got a really neat
parallaxing going on, all of
that kind of stuff.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah, so maybe
we'll show you a little
bit, in case you haven't
seen the experience.
PETE LEPAGE: All right, well if
we can bring up the screen.
Great.
AUBREY ANDERSON: It looks
like it's happening.
So I'm just going hold off on
the microphone for now.
So what we've done, we've tried
to keep to sort of a
theatrical approach
but do that with
elements in the browser.
And I'm just going to rotate
this model as we look at.
These are all divs, which is a
sort of important distinction
from technologies like WebGL or
other ways that you might
manipulate content in 3D.
But the other challenge we
had is integrating video.
So in this example, you'll see,
as obviously in the real
experience, you can't turn the
model around because that sort
of blows it.
But I think it's sort of good to
understand how these things
are stacked up in 3D space.
We have the front layer here,
which is a video element.
That's a piece of
WebM that we're
loading and playing back.
And that has the same background
in the same
proportions as you see when the
interactive part of the
experience starts.
But if I flip it here,
you'll see that's
the back of the video.
There's the sea, which is
actually titled away from us a
little bit.
And then these other elements,
the links, and the back plate.
And if you can see, even farther
behind that, is sort
of the sky, and the sea,
and some kind of
foggy elements there.
And as the video plays out, what
it does is it just kind
of crossfades to the 3D elements
behind it and creates
this kind of relatively
fluid experience.
I think it's just about to
go in to crossfade here.
KC AUSTIN: We actually build the
scene in CSS with all the
separate elements first.
Screenshot that, composited
that screenshot into the
background plate of the video,
and then that got exported at
WebM, so it crossfades
perfectly.
AUBREY ANDERSON: So there's
a real back and forth.
And for post-production people,
this is kind of a new
idea because they're used to
just sort of getting a
drawing, getting some art,
and then having to
put that in the video.
But in this case, that
was only the start.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So now one of the things I know
we were playing with and
looking at early on was that
WebM doesn't do alpha
transparency yet.
AUBREY ANDERSON: It's true.
Fortunately, for everybody,
I think that's coming.
And we worked with the animation
codec as a way to
kind of comp these things
together, which does do video
transparency.
Obviously you can't put that on
the web because the files
are hundreds of meg.
But one of the things we look
forward to is being able to
actually live composite these
elements right into the scene.
So rather than having a back
plate inside the video like we
saw and having to do this sort
hoop jumping of switching it
out, we'll be able to just
make the background
transparent, key out the
characters, and just park them
right in the 3D model,
which is just going
to be insanely powerful.
KC AUSTIN: And all the scenes
are actually built now.
Even the contortionist scene
with the tree behind it, the
tree was built with CSS, with
every strip of bark on it is a
different PNG.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh wow.
KC AUSTIN: So it's built in
3D and rotated behind the
characters.
And as soon as we found out
that alpha wasn't going to
make it, we set it up to
screenshot it, composite it
again behind.
But all the scenes are set
up, so they do work
if you had the alpha.
PETE LEPAGE: So we have a case
study that I sort of took this
particular scene and took it
apart and sort of built each
of the pieces individually.
But why don't we open up the dev
tools and have a look at,
or even some real code,
and have a look at
what's going on here.
Like how is this built?
AUBREY ANDERSON: I think that's
a super great idea.
The other think I just wanted to
point out also is that you
can kind of keep going
in Z space.
So here, if you hit back button,
we have the pink man.
And this is just sort
of non sequitur.
It's just something that
happens if you
happen to find this.
PETE LEPAGE: It's a nice
little Easter egg.
AUBREY ANDERSON: A little
Easter egg, exactly.
You can zoom the whole model out
and you can keep going in
3D space, both forward and back,
and left and right, and
up and down.
Yeah, probably the easiest
thing is to just sort of
inspect some of this stuff
as a way to get started.
KC AUSTIN: Start with like the
rotational containers?
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah.
I can kind of show you some
of the anatomy of how
this is built out.
This is probably small
text for you guys.
Sorry about that.
But you will at least get a
sense of how the rotation is
accomplished.
We have several div containers
which have 3D prospective
applied to them via CSS.
And I think one of the biggest
brain challenges is not
thinking of elements as singular
and transformable by
themselves.
A lot of times, a complex
transformation is happening
because the element is moving
and its container is moving on
a different axis, and its
container is moving maybe on a
different axis.
So we find this model is
generally contained in three
boxes and each box generally
handles one axis of the
rotation, which gives us kind of
an infinite flexibility in
moving this model around.
We can move it up and down, left
and right, and kind of
tilt it all around.
But that requires three
containers to really
accomplish it in the way
that you would want.
I think I see when people first
approach CSS and 3D,
they're like, well, I have the
element, and I put it, I
rotated it, and then I wanted to
rotate it that way as well,
and that didn't work.
And it's like, well, it's a
container within a container.
It's just a slightly different
way to think about it.
KC AUSTIN: It's a lot easier to
think about it that way, to
separate out the translates
and the rotates as well.
Because in the CSS transform,
you have to have translate 3D
and rotate within the
same transform
block in the same string.
So if you break those out, you
now can have the translate 3D
on one div and then the
container and then another
container have the rotate, and
you can affect them separately
and not have to worry about.
AUBREY ANDERSON: So I just
wanted to kind of point out a
couple of things.
We also lean very heavily
on animation.
So I'll show you this behavior
really quick.
So when this v first loads,
you'll see it sort of does
this long drift down here.
And you are sort of drifting
through this
kind of 3D star field.
Each of these stars is a PNG
file that KC has placed in
real space, more or less.
PETE LEPAGE: There's
one scene that just
sort of blew me away.
The one scene where the women
are blowing the little
fireflies off.
And just the fact that each one
of those stars is its own
item that sort of moves
in space and time.
KC AUSTIN: Yeah, each
one has a class.
It's just one class for a star
that has this tiny PNG and I
just looped through a couple
hundred times, placed them in
random positions in Z, X, Y. And
it kind of gives you that
parallaxing feel when you
rotate everything.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah, that's
this view here.
This is an interesting
view as well.
Each of these elements is
obviously, we're accomplishing
transparency here, but not in
the way you might think.
This is a video that we're
making manually by using a
long animation and moving a
background sprite around.
So each of these women is
actually a big sprite sheet of
PNGs that we're applying an
animation and stepping from
scene to scene.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, very cool.
OK.
KC AUSTIN: Since we move through
that scene, we can't
do any sort of background
compositing behind the videos.
So in this case, we had
to do a sprite sheet.
And it's basically like
an insanely large PNG.
PETE LEPAGE: Wow.
KC AUSTIN: But I mean, even then
as an optimized PNG, it's
like maybe a meg and a half
per sprite sheet.
So it's not as big as a
video would be anyway.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, like I was
going to say, compare that to
a video, and it's pretty much
the same size or smaller in
some cases.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Just if you're
starting from scratch
with this technology, I think
it's just important to
understand how things
get glued together.
So you'll see in the code
here, we're applying a
transform on this element.
This has an interesting
side effect.
When you translate something 3D,
it also will bounce that
element down into the hardware,
essentially put it
in the GPU's stack, rather
than having the
CPU have to do it.
And also, importantly, think
in terms of prefixes.
This is probably how
you will start
working with it in Chrome.
We use a framework called
Neutrino, which helps us
simplify some of the language.
And each of these, in a
different browser context,
will have a different prefix.
Like that for Mozilla, like that
for Opera, and like that
sort of the various WebKits,
Chrome, Safari,
that type of thing.
We've done that.
There's a couple of frameworks
out there that will
help you with this.
PETE LEPAGE: That's awesome.
AUBREY ANDERSON:
It's just nice.
This is how it will look
in a year or two.
So just to get yourself thinking
in terms of the
unprefixed syntax sooner
than later.
And just kind of a
couple things to
try to parse through.
There are transforms and
there are animations.
And animations are just
sequences of CSS state.
Generally they're sequences of
transform state, but they can
be any state you want.
You can go from a big fat
border to a tiny border.
You can go from a blue
background to a red
background.
And what the CSS animation
engine does is it essentially
tweens those states for you.
So you express yourself
in terms of
where you want to start.
I want the element to begin 700
pixels back in Z space.
So these three elements, this
is X, this is Y, and this is
Z. And I would like it to end
transformed 90 pixels over,
that's 90 pixels to the right.
1,400 pixels down, that's a
push down on the y-axis.
And 100 pixels forward
in Z space.
So you can kind of think
this through.
The element is moving from
somewhere back there to a
little bit forward of, if you
think of zero, that's the
plane of your browser,
sort of.
But it's moving forward in
space, as well as down.
It's also a scaling.
So actually, a really immense
amount of stuff if you were
thinking of this, trying to
accomplish this in, say, a
canvas, this would be very,
very hard to express.
Just this simple thing, you'd
have to get really granular
about what was happening to
the element fame by frame.
But here, we just say start
here and end here, take 25
seconds to make that happen.
And you can even apply some kind
of using easing, sort of
Robert Penner style
math to how you
begin and end the animation.
In this case, ease in/out means
that it will sort of
have a parabolic ramp up, get to
a midpoint, and then have a
parabolic ramp down, which just
gives it a little more
organic feel.
KC AUSTIN: We tried to use
animation as much as we could.
Like the bubbles, when you
create a bubble, you just
place it in a random position,
and then just
add a class to it.
And when you add that class,
it adds the ascendant key
frame animation and
the bubble rises.
So you don't have
to go through.
It's just as simple as
creating the div.
PETE LEPAGE: And adding
that class--
KC AUSTIN: And then it goes.
PETE LEPAGE: --and it
all happens for you.
KC AUSTIN: And if you create
those at different times, then
you'd get a bunch of bubble
all floating up.
PETE LEPAGE: Very cool.
One of the things I noticed as I
started playing with some of
these 3D animations was that
when you apply a transform on
the z-axis, it pushes it back,
but it also does exactly what
physics says it should do.
AUBREY ANDERSON: It
gets smaller.
PETE LEPAGE: And it
makes it smaller.
AUBREY ANDERSON: That's true.
PETE LEPAGE: So that's one of
those ones where keeping in
mind that scale factor
is really important.
Because you're going to put
something back or move it
really close, all of a sudden
it's going to go from being
whatever size you expected
it to be to
being bigger or smaller.
AUBREY ANDERSON: I think that's
another important thing
to keep in mind too, that what
you get from the rendering
engine generally reflects
reality, but for an
interactive environment
that's not always
what you want to do.
It's a little bit like
deceleration physics on a
touch device.
They're not real physics because
real physics actually
don't feel that good.
Like the way an element really
decelerates in space, from an
interactive perspective is
kind of not that cool.
So the same with transforms,
a lot of times we'll find
ourselves subtly scaling things
up or down and actually
pulling them out of whatever
you might characterize as
realism in terms of a real 3D
model, if you're thinking in
terms of like WebGL terms.
But in order to make them sit
right compositionally and just
to make when your brain looks
at you go, oh yeah, probably
that tree and that person
are in the same world.
Oftentimes you have to bring
the person way forward and
scale them way down.
Because bringing them forward
makes them big, and even
though that is the right
perspective, you have to scale
them down in order to just
buy it compositionally.
I'll show you another example.
So these lanterns, you'll see
they're sort of randomized,
and they kind of float out, and
then eventually will shoot
up into the sky.
Again, this programmatically
would be relatively difficult
to express because you'd have to
sort of micromanage each of
these elements.
But in our case here, we
don't actually have
to do that at all.
We have a lantern.
This is how every
lantern starts.
And we have a little
particle generator
that makes a new lantern.
Every time a lantern gets thrown
up there, it's pushed a
little bit in left space.
It has some sort of width and
height, and all the stuff
you'd normally do to a div
to get it to render.
And we set a starting point.
And then we just attach an
animation to it every time it
gets added.
And I think the attachment of
the animation can happen also
in JavaScript, which
is important.
You can sort of wait.
And in this case, the lanterns
start all hidden.
And in JavaScript when the video
is ended, we get the
ended event on the video, and
we kick off these sort of
lantern animations.
PETE LEPAGE: So the lanterns
can start floating in.
AUBREY ANDERSON: They can start
floating in, exactly.
But then we can forget about
it, which is awesome.
The lanterns all go through
this same transformation.
But JavaScript, as it loops
through, is setting a
different time on
the animation.
So the speed at which
they go through it
will change and randomize.
The place they start, X and Y,
But what happens from there
is always the same.
It goes through this
transform, it
drifts basically up.
But if you think of it in 3D
space, up sort of means away
because we're also scaling them
down as they drift up.
So you can see the go from this
sort of Y positioning up
to slightly less
Y positioning.
And then in the last 10% of the
animation, they shoot way
up in Y, which has the visual
effect of making them go up
into space.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, I think
that's one of my favorite
things about the animation, is
being able to say, hey, I
start at zero, and obviously
I'm going to
specify my end animation.
But you can also put in sort of
middle points where you can
say, hey, I want the middle
point to be maybe at 80%.
You can get that math
built yourself.
Like you could go, oh hey,
I want it to go how
I want it to work.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Absolutely, and
you can get really sort of
propeller heady about it.
This I believe is five
digit precision.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, wow, I didn't
know that actually.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Some browsers
have three digit precision, so
I recommended keeping
to three.
But I believe Chrome actually
observes five.
So you can get very,
very specific.
This in a four second animation,
obviously, is not
something you'd do very often.
But if you have a very
long-lived animation,
something that takes 100
seconds, or 500 seconds,
sometimes to get the timing just
right, like when you're
motion mapping video.
KC AUSTIN: That's what we were
doing for the videos.
I actually wrote something so
that when you hit the Space
bar during a video, it would
get put the time over the
duration and log that.
And then I could just
copy, paste that
into here and do that.
And that's how we would track
where things to sync things up
with video.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Oh,
that's cool.
So you'd leave the video rolling
and just go tap.
KC AUSTIN: The video rolling,
and I'd be like, OK, I want
that to happen here, and then
boom, and then just copy that
in, and that's where that
key frame basically is.
It's kind of like
a queue point.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Chrome as a
tool for motion mapping.
That's pretty badass.
So do you want to talk about the
fireflies at little bit.
KC AUSTIN: Yeah, so the
fireflies, I thought about how
we could do with that sort of
the key frame animation, but
we needed them more reactive.
So when they're made, they're
generated, and then they sort
of fly down the path in front of
you in Z. And then when you
get to the next scene at the
fork, they kind of split and
go left and right.
And that's where you
can choose a path,
either left or right.
And when you lean left, they
have to all kind of
hover to the left.
When you lean right, they have
to hover to the right.
So in that case, since they're
reactive, we couldn't really
use the key frame animations.
So as you can see here, they're
kind of just flying
down in front of you.
So there's a state that they all
look for that's out in the
main application that's
called control.
And if that's set to center,
they just go in the center.
If that's set to right, they
all move to the right, if
that's set to left.
So you can call that
from anywhere,
and set that variable.
For example, right now--
AUBREY ANDERSON: You'll see
them, there, they're more or
less centered.
Or they're split, right?
KC AUSTIN: Left and right.
If you just make this variable
control, if you set it to
right, you'll see them
all kind of--
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, and they
all move to the right.
KC AUSTIN: --they all
meander over.
And then if you set it
to split, they split.
And then if you set it to left,
they'll all meander over
to the other side.
And these, there's an object.
There's a few ways that I was
experimenting with doing this.
There was the jQuery
thing where you can
add data to a div.
And that was the first thing.
But I ended up just doing the
way that I'm used to doing,
which is I have an object that's
a firefly JavaScript
object that has all the X, Y, Z
positions and the logic for
updating it, the particle.
So it's a very simple
particle system that
updates on every frame.
And then I have a loop
that goes through
and updates all those.
And then within that object,
there's also a
reference to the div.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Are those
guys their own view?
KC AUSTIN: Yeah, they
have their own view.
It's fireflies.js.
So you'll see, this is
the fireflies object.
Oh, this is the control here,
so that could be center,
split, and then disperse just
sends them off of the screen.
Where to generate them in the
beginning is a whole other
thing to get into.
But we needed them to actually
show up at the end of the hand
when the siren actually
raise her hand.
So what I had to do was find the
X and Y position of that
sprite sheet and then go into
the sprite sheet in Photoshop
and see how many pixels left
and top where the hand is.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh wow.
KC AUSTIN: And add that to
the sprite sheet X and Y.
PETE LEPAGE: So you were going,
OK, here's my sprite
sheet, I know that the
hand ends at this.
KC AUSTIN: And the hand
pixels where I want
it to form is there.
And then you add that to the
X, Y, Z of the sprite sheet
and then that places it where
you want it to go.
With then you call that on the
WebKit animation iteration.
So when that iteration is done,
the sprite sheet is
ended, that's when her hand is
up, create the thing, and then
it just goes by itself.
And you can see it in the
update loop here.
This is all the variables
for the set-up.
And if it's left, it sets
the center and border.
If it's right, it sets the
center and border.
If it's split, it checks if
its ID is even or odd.
If it's even, then it goes to
one side, if it's odd, it goes
to the other.
And if it disperses, it just
takes off, off the screen, and
doesn't mind the borders.
It's a very simple
particle system.
But for this, we had to
update it on every
frame with the interval.
AUBREY ANDERSON: And then, let's
look at the CSS as well
just as kind of see how they
get bound together.
Because the fireflies
themselves have a--
KC AUSTIN: Yeah, they also have
an animation on them.
And the CSS animation is
to make them blink.
AUBREY ANDERSON: So each of
these elements, every time you
add a div, you give it the class
firefly, it's going to
obey these directions here, and
bind itself to the firefly
light animation.
And it'll do this independently
of whatever
JavaScript is doing to the div
that actually contains them.
This bit just keeps
running on a loop.
KC AUSTIN: And since they're
created at different times,
then they blink at
different times.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah, these
will all go from zero.
Animations are also interesting
in the sense that
when the element is visible,
the animation runs.
But they'll clean
themselves up.
If you set the elements to
display none, the animation
stops and unloads.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, cool.
AUBREY ANDERSON: So we were sort
of pleasantly surprised
by how much management
you get.
We never have to go in and
cancel the information.
KC AUSTIN: Like for the bubbles
for example, when we
would create the bubble, it
would play the animation.
And then on WebKit end, we were
settings display to none,
that would clear
the animation.
PETE LEPAGE: Then it's
not taking up memory.
Something like this--
KC AUSTIN: It's not on
the render queue.
PETE LEPAGE: --if every piece
of bark on some of these
things is its own element--
KC AUSTIN: Oh yeah,
it gets heavy.
PETE LEPAGE: --you got
to start thinking
about a lot of usage.
KC AUSTIN: Or if you're
generating bubbles every
second, the divs start
piling up.
Actually for the bubbles, on
WebKit end I was actually
removing the div.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Oh right,
when the animation ends,
[INAUDIBLE], you can just
take the div out.
PETE LEPAGE: And there's an
event that's fired when the
animation--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PETE LEPAGE: --oh, that event.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Both transition
and animation get a
start and an end.
And animations get an iteration,
which means that
like if it's looping over
a second, you'll get an
iteration called [INAUDIBLE].
You can actually fake a
setTimeout that way.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, very nice.
AUBREY ANDERSON: I didn't say
that and I don't recommend it.
PETE LEPAGE: Now, actually
that's a good point.
I assume you guys used
requestAnimationFrame as
opposed to setTimeout for?
AUBREY ANDERSON: We ended up
using setTimeout for almost
everything, primarily for
compatibility's sake.
Because requestAnimationFrame,
I think, is cooler and better
objectively speaking.
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Obviously this
is a Chrome experiment,
but we wanted to be as
compatible as possible when
you took it to another
environment.
And not all environments speak
requestAnimationFrame, with
some notable exceptions.
And then in testing also,
I did a bunch of sort of
parallel testing in terms of
setting timeouts that way,
setting them with animation,
setting them with setTimeouts.
The main thing about setTimeout
is that you just
have to be really careful
that you don't
leave anybody hanging.
So when you view tears down,
you just have to make sure
that any time you set a timeout
you keep a reference
to it, and as your view tears
down, you cancel.
And I think timeout has got such
a bad name for a number
of reasons, but that's
one of them.
It's very easy to make
terrible mistakes.
KC AUSTIN: I think we'd prefer
to do the animation frame,
because it is clocked
like exactly.
But for this kind of stuff
too, it's just fireflies
flying around the screen, it
doesn't have to be perfectly
precise at exactly 60 frames
a second or exactly
whatever you need.
So as long as they move around
realistically, the interval
works fine, as long as
you clear it after.
AUBREY ANDERSON: And
for us, there's
so much media happening.
So a lot of times, our timing,
the holder of the master clock
is actually a piece of video
or a piece of music.
So if you look at like the
tree, for instance.
PETE LEPAGE: And just as a
reminder, if people have
questions, please go and post
those on Google Moderator so
we can come back to some of
these in a little bit.
And as well, you can go visit
this at MoviKantiRevo.com.
It's available as
of last night.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah,
I heard it launched.
PETE LEPAGE: Woo-hoo.
Yay.
AUBREY ANDERSON: So in this one,
we have one big animation
which is transforming the
whole model, essentially
creating a pan up effect.
But we're not really panning
up, obviously.
One big div containing
everything is actually
animation down very slowly.
And then there's all these sort
of individual pieces of
video that we're listening to,
specific events, the start,
the end, and, in some cases,
various timing events.
So there's multiple things
happening, but there's no
setTimeouts in this context.
We're looking at how much time
has elapsed in the animation
and how much time has elapsed
in a given piece of media.
And those things are keeping
time for us.
The advantage there is if for
some reason somebody hits this
on a slow network connection and
the video takes an extra
five seconds to start, obviously
you don't want your
timing to get all messed up.
So pretty much up to lean on the
video to kind of run the
clock and tell you what's
happening when.
KC AUSTIN: We also have a simple
queue point script in
there that tracks the video on
video update and tracks what
time it is.
And then you have an array that
has times and functions
that fire during those times.
So as soon as it hits those
times, it will fire those
functions off.
So you can bring up the video,
see what time exactly you want
that to fire.
Like on the curtain, when she
leans, we need to trigger the
curtain to open.
So we just say at five seconds,
trigger the current
left, and then it'll
fire that.
AUBREY ANDERSON: One of the
things I'd love to see happen
in the media tags, in general,
is some sort of a better way
to plug into what's happening
in the media world.
Like a of times, we have to
manually set up a framework to
observe a piece of media.
The media tells us a lot when
it's loading and about whether
it can play or can't play.
Once it's rolling, it's kind
of quiet unless you ask it,
and basically just go
in and getTime.
You get the element and ask
it for current time.
And current time will give
you seconds and sometimes
milliseconds.
And then you have to kind of
infer from what's going on.
But it'd be great to have that
API get deeper someday and be
able to have the media tell us
and create callbacks that we
can listen for.
It's very new, it's very
young, so there's a
lot going on there.
PETE LEPAGE: I think there's
so many opportunities.
We've got like the now with
the Web Audio API.
Hopefully we'll be able to get
something potentially similar
sort of for video that we'll
be able to get a lot more
stuff with.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Oh yeah,
and we had high hopes.
Obviously, we're using Web
Audio and WebRTC in this.
But one of the things we ran
into, which I think just got
fixed in Canary, like yesterday,
was the ability to
essentially loop those
things back and plug
them into one another.
Which you wouldn't think would
be that big a deal, but it's
actually a super, super
important when creating things
like voice control.
So what we had hoped to
accomplish here was to allow
us to listen to the camera
and microphone.
And obviously, we're painting
the camera frames
in here with a canvas.
But the audio, we cannot, or
at least have not been able
to, sort of feed that back into
the Web Audio API and
analyze it.
Our sort of dream for some of
these sections was she would
come up and ask you to whistle,
you would whistle, we
would look at the frequency and
use Web Audio to sort of
analyze whether you had hit a
certain frequency range, and
create different behaviors
based on low tone, a high
tone, a loud sound,
a quiet sound.
And that's something that I
think we will get to as we go.
But it's really exciting to see
that kind of come about.
And there was a bug filed
about it already.
But we jumped on the bug and
we're like, well we're trying
to do this, and this,
and this.
And then we saw other people
kind of go, oh yeah, we want
to do that too.
So I think it built some
momentum and has now actually
been sorted out.
PETE LEPAGE: So let's talk about
the facial detection,
getUserMedia, and what's
going on there.
Because you start Movi Kanti
Revo for the first time and it
says, hey, this application
wants to use your webcam and
microphone, do you
want to allow?
And you click Yes, and all of
a sudden, there's your face.
What's going on there?
AUBREY ANDERSON: So there's a
bunch of stuff going on there.
The first thing happens is
when you click Allow, it
creates a video tag.
And it sets the source of that
video tag to whatever
WebRTC gives you.
WebRTC gives you this sort of
string of gobbledygook, which
is really just a kind of a
reference, I think, so that
the system can bind
up to the feed
coming in from the camera.
But that's really
only step one.
The video tag doesn't get you
very far in terms of doing
motion tracking or anything
like that.
To do that, you really
need to use canvas,
at least right now.
So you never actually see the
video that we bring in.
The first thing you see
is a canvas element.
This canvas element has some
sort of vignetting going on
and some other treatments,
which is why I'm sort of
partially transparent here.
But the sort of meat of what's
happening is that the frames
from the video are getting
pulled into the canvas, we're
then blowing through
the pixel.
The pixels of the canvas gives
you a sort of big and
unfortunately convoluted
pixel array.
So it's actually just a big
single list of pixels.
And pixels 0, 1 2, and 3, are
the R, G, B, and A of the
first pixel.
Those are the first
four slots.
So you have to take the slots
of the array, four by four,
and just make a note for
yourself that every four means
a pixel, and start your start to
pixel-level analysis there
and that way.
So we're using a couple
of things.
One is this really fantastic,
and reasonably fast JavaScript
CCV library to recognize face.
It's very fast, but it's still
JavaScript, so it's
comparatively slow to
like native code.
So every second or so, we do
face detection and average out
the things like the size and
the location of your face.
And so, if you kind of lean it,
it's keyed to zoom, and
that will sort of trigger
the zoom in.
Leaning out will sort
of push out, again,
with the zoom level.
And then from there, we're just
looking at what I think
of as pretty traditional
motion detection.
And Jason who's not here wrote
this, and he's very smart.
So it blows through pixels, it
looks at an interval, it looks
at what that pixel looked like
last time it checked and what
it looks like now.
And so it's a threshold
for a difference.
So if that pixel is these
different enough, that is the
color or the tone has changed
past a certain threshold, we
call that motion.
So that means there's
something happening.
There's some places where
that falls down.
But actually, in practice,
especially with a laptop or
whatever sitting on the table,
it's pretty darn accurate, and
actually very, very fast.
Fast enough for where this is
probably 15 or 18 frames per
second, and we're still doing
all this other stuff, and 3D
transforms, and animations
and stuff.
So we're definitely beating
up the JavaScript
run time pretty badly.
But it's OK, it actually runs.
PETE LEPAGE: We're pushing
the browser pretty hard.
KC AUSTIN: And we threw
everything else onto the GPU
with the translate 3D.
So that frees up all the CPU
that we can this other stuff.
AUBREY ANDERSON: It's that
sort of balance.
Anything that you can say, here,
graphics card, and get
it out of--
PETE LEPAGE: You go do this.
AUBREY ANDERSON: I mean this
is a huge difference.
This is sort of a tangent.
But like the way we used to do
it with JavaScript, or like if
you do jquery.animate, or
anything that is essentially
clock-based animation where
JavaScript is setting timeouts
or running an interval and
observing elements.
It's just dog slow compared to,
an even with a very fast
JavaScript run time, it's that
sort of single-threaded like
JavaScript has to think
about every frame.
Which, I think there's 150
lanterns, there's this
background animation happening,
there are all these
elements positioned in 3D space,
the canvas analysis,
the video coming in, there's
a lot going on
even in this one page.
PETE LEPAGE: So I think that
one of the things that just
sort of blew me away with the
getUserMedia and WebRTC is
like you get access to the
camera, of course, user's
permission first.
You then take that, render that
onto canvas, you can do
whatever you want with
it from there.
It's not going anywhere.
All that video's sitting
on your local machine.
So you're doing all that
analysis there.
And then being able to make an
entire scene and the world
move about in that way.
So as your head goes one way,
you start to tilt the world.
To go back to the 3D transforms
we were talking
about earlier, you start
applying those.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah, in the
real app we have thresholds on
these 3D transforms.
I've turned them off for the
sake of this demo so you can
see and spin the whole model
all the way around.
PETE LEPAGE: Is that something
that developers
can go do very easily?
Is there a place with dev
tools they can go?
KC AUSTIN: There was one
variable author mode that
turned it on.
But since, you'd have to just
take one condition out.
But yeah, it's just
one condition.
AUBREY ANDERSON:
It's tweakable.
Maybe I'll send it to you and
you can post it somewhere.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, that
would be kind of cool.
Because it really is one
of those fun things for
developers to go, oh, hey,
I want to take this part.
I want to see what's going on
behind each of these pieces.
AUBREY ANDERSON: And you don't
even have to do that by
tweaking variables.
You can actually go into the
inspector and just change the
translate 3D state
of the element.
And almost all the
elements here are
transform in 3D space.
And so you can just go in and
change the rotate Y value and
or add a rotate Y value if
it doesn't have one.
And you'll see it do this.
KC AUSTIN: You do to force
perspective container and go
into the X, Y, Z of that.
And you can sort of do
whatever you want.
AUBREY ANDERSON:
Move it around.
PETE LEPAGE: See how
that happens.
AUBREY ANDERSON: I like that
you get to see the back
of the video too.
You don't have to have this,
but we've left it on just
because it's kind of cool.
PETE LEPAGE: Well, that
was one of the things.
I don't think we ended
up doing it.
But I remember us talking about
it at one point, was
like an Easter egg where like
if you actually turned the
scene around all the way, you
actually would see sort of
back, like almost backstage
kind of thing.
AUBREY ANDERSON:
Yeah, totally.
We had kind of a long list of
extra wonderful things that
time is always against
you in trying to
actually ship something.
But yeah, there are
several little
things if you dig around.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
AUBREY ANDERSON: I'm not
giving them all way.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, we definitely
don't want.
We've given one good one.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah,
there's at least one
good one we gave away.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So one of the other things that
we thought about with
this experiment was mobile
experiences, right?
Do you want to talk a
little bit about how
you approached that?
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah, I guess
there's another sort of
important side effect to letting
CSS do a lot of this
heavy lifting for you.
One is obviously it's
just easier on the
JavaScript run time.
But the other kind
of cool thing is
that it's very portable.
So any other browser runtime
that thinks about things this
way will allow you to render
these elements on the GPU of
whatever device you happen
to be looking at.
And so we're kind of fortunate
to be coming into an era where
a lot of browsers speak the
same, or at least subtle
variance of the same language,
and will do the same things
with those instructions, so
particularly animations and
transforms.
So as we set something like
transform translate 3D, we now
have support for this in pretty
much, at least the
latest releases of, all major
browsers and mobile.
And in the mobile space it is
particularly important because
obviously your CPU is pegged
down quite a bit.
You're generally running
on sometimes dual core.
Now but it's still
100 megahertz.
And its a phone, it's also doing
whatever the phone needs
to do, and there's
a lot going, it's
not just the browser.
And so the ability to take
elements in the browser and
render them on the graphics
hardware is really, really
huge and really important.
And if you look at this
experience on tablets, you
actually get pretty competent
rendering, and, in some cases,
really kickass rendering just by
virtue of this same thing.
And places where we don't have
a really good JavaScript run
time, we can dodge that to some
extent by rendering right
on the hardware.
PETE LEPAGE: Now we don't have
getUserMedia on mobile.
So instead, it did something I
thought was brilliant and it
makes perfect sense.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah, what we
did on mobile is we pegged
that behavior to tilt.
So as you tilt, you'll see this
kind of interface here,
which is like a little
four-way controller.
This is a poor man's D-pad.
And as you tilt, you will get
the sort of same effect as if
we detected motion on the
left and right side.
PETE LEPAGE: So tilt device
orientation, so that as you
tilt the device it gets
that same thing.
And it's pretty rare that I'm
going to pick up my laptop or
desktop and go, oo, look,
I can do this.
I've done it A. Few times for
a quick little demo and it's
kind of fun.
But you're not going to give
your kid your laptop and say,
hey, go play with Movi Kanti
Revo and tilt it.
So it doesn't work there, but
it works so beautifully on
mobile where people just
naturally think, oh, cool.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah, we tried
to on mobile side do the
thing that you would think
that it would do to the
greatest extent that we could,
so wherever possible just
tried to do the right
thing and the thing
that you might expect.
KC AUSTIN: We have sort of this
higher level thing that
makes it lean either way, and
then that will accept input
from wherever you want.
So if it's the widget that has
the video stuff, that'll tell
it, or the tilt, or whatever
else we wanted.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah, you can
really map any input into the
general rotation controller and
wire up whatever type of
control you want.
So you could easily wire
it touch, or keyboard.
PETE LEPAGE: So we could even,
like, game pack controllers.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah,
we could do game pack
controllers.
PETE LEPAGE: HTML5 has got the
API for doing that, so like
you could [INAUDIBLE].
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah, there's
some potential there.
PETE LEPAGE: That would
be really fun.
That would be really
net to go do.
We've been playing with one
for our Chrome Apps.
We've got one of the Parrot
Drone helicopters.
And we managed to make it fly
using purely HTML and
JavaScript with a Chrome
App, which is like tons
of fun to go to.
I'm going to start pull up some
of the questions to see
if people have submitted
stuff.
But what was your favorite
part of this project?
AUBREY ANDERSON: I don't know.
Do you have a favorite part?
KC AUSTIN: Just overall,
probably just getting to the
point where I can be creative
without having to think about
the CSS, and all the code
and everything.
Getting to a point where I can
set things up, get things
moving around, build these
scenes out without thinking
about the code anymore.
I think that's the best thing,
when you finally get to the
point where you're not thinking
about how things
should be set up.
Because we went to so many
iterations of do we do CSS
animations, do we do JavaScript,
how do we have the
scenes set up in 3D?
Once you get to the point
where all that kind of
workflow is all settled, and
then you can take the assets
from getting build something
at the end, I think
that's the best part.
AUBREY ANDERSON: I really
liked also when we were
shooting in Las Vegas.
We had a lot of these models
or at least preliminary
versions of the models built.
And so we were able to take
really quick keys from the
camera and just make me
quick movie files.
And they were sort of res'ed
out and stuff, but we were
able to drop those right into
the environment as we had them
mocked up and show the actors,
show the performers what they
were going to look like
in the environment.
And they were like, ah, OK,
I see, so I'm in a forest.
And I think when they went
back and did another take
after seeing it, I think it
changed their idea, and it
gave them a real sense of
what was happening.
And I think it changed the
quality of the performance
because they could actually
previsualized.
PETE LEPAGE: Well they were
in this blue screen room.
Like literally it was this
cube of just pure blue.
And it's hard to imagine in that
without having something
to start with where
you're going.
KC AUSTIN: And mocking the
scenes up and just having
layers is really fast.
So you could just have that set
up, throw them in, show
them how it looks, even change
stuff on the fly.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah, move
things up and down in Z space,
scale things around.
And because it's all CSS and
you're not down there making a
code level change and forgetting
a semicolon or
whatever, it's very, very quick
and easy to change.
You can change it right
in the inspector.
It was, I would say, my first
experience with something that
was that real time with that
kind of media production.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, and to see
them all come over and look at
this, like they were
just so amazed.
And in fact, some of the artists
were at the launch
last night.
Like we've been heads
down in this.
We've seen this--
AUBREY ANDERSON: They'd
never seen it.
PETE LEPAGE: --hours, and hours,
and hours a day, and
they had never seen it.
And the look of sort of joy,
and glee, and excitement on
their face to see them in this
world was pretty phenomenal.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Right on.
I had to talk, I missed that.
But I'm glad that happened.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
So a couple questions
from the audience.
And please post anymore as we're
going through these.
But the first question was,
somebody tried to run it on
some of the older browsers, so
like Firefox 3.6, and IE 9,
and it doesn't degrade
gracefully.
And besides WebRTC not working,
why didn't it work in
those older browsers?
AUBREY ANDERSON: The big barrier
is the ability to
translate elements
in 3D space.
And sort of early on we were
like, well, if we do it this
way, we are going to
lose some of the
older browser renderers.
But this being a Chrome
experiment, we wanted to
really show the latest, greatest
and do the really
best we could do with the
technology that we have on the
sort of leading edge.
Not that WebKit transform is
particularly, but broad
support is pretty new.
So the big barrier for older
browsers is that they will not
translate elements
in 3D space.
A lot of them have translate Y,
they have translate X, or
they have a translate function
that takes an X and a Y, but
there's no Z. And they also
don't do that work
largely on the GPU.
So the barrier for us was a
browser run time that when you
ask it to put an element,
position it in 3D space, it
would do that for you, and do
the right thing, and hopefully
do it on the graphics card
wherever possible.
So you'll see this on Windows XP
as well, like Chrome ships
with acceleration turned off
by default on Windows XP.
And so even though Chrome can
do it, they, I think, can't
reliably be certain of the GPU
environment, so they hedge the
bet and ship it off.
You can go into about:flags
and turn it back on.
But the browser that can't speak
that language, we had to
just let those ones go.
KC AUSTIN: Or even you could
have the newest version of
Chrome but with a super old GPU,
it just won't know what
to do with those layers.
PETE LEPAGE: And one of the
really important things about
Chrome experiments is they are
meant push the web forward and
show what's possible
on the web.
And that's sort of one of those
things where this works
in many, almost all of the
modern browsers without any
craziness going on.
And so we want to push that.
We want people to look at this
and go, holy smokes, this is
all HTML, I can do
this myself.
I can go in and look this.
There's nothing proprietary.
You can view source on
the code on this.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah, and
change the whole thing.
And I mean, I think it's also
important to really understand
that this is an art piece.
I mean, we're not
trying to sell
refrigerators from this website.
Like we're trying to do creative
work with new tools
that we have discovered
in modern browsers.
And that's, I think, the
experiment part of the Chrome
experiment.
We're fundamentally pretty
creative people, and that's
where our hearts
and minds are.
We're also technical.
But the point of this whole
process was to take the tools
that we have discovered in the
browser, push them as hard as
we could in the name
of doing something
artistic and creative.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool, awesome.
The next question, was it easier
to do this in HTML and
JavaScript than it
was in Flash?
AUBREY ANDERSON: Oh,
that's interesting.
PETE LEPAGE: And we talked last
night, you came from a
Flash world.
KC AUSTIN: Yeah, I've been in
the Flash world since '98.
I helped shape the plug-in.
I've been working on it for
years, and years, and years.
And it's not so much a
matter of could we do
it better in Flash.
Flash has all kinds of different
effects, and
filters, and everything
but [INAUDIBLE]
level stuff.
And you do get the webcam across
all browsers, which
would be great.
But it's more the point of being
challenging and doing it
without Flash.
And this is the future.
So I think we have to push it.
And eventually, we will
have everything
that we have in Flash.
We already have the
CSS filters now.
With canvas we're getting
bitmap level effects.
So it's getting there and we
just need to push it forward
until it is 100%.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, and I think
this is something that we will
absolutely get to.
And this is something that is,
I think, in many ways, much
more accessible to people.
KC AUSTIN: Yeah, and if you
say, we could have had the
microphone in Flash, and we
actually thought about having
just one element just to grab
the microphone and pipe it in
just from Flash.
But we decided against it just
because we wanted it to be
complete a complete
HTML5 experience.
And now, yesterday, we do have
audio in Canary, and because
of the fact that we're
pushing it forward.
So the next thing that we
do, we will have that.
AUBREY ANDERSON: I also think
it's really important that
this is markup.
We're doing things
declaratively, by and large,
in this application, which is
fundamentally a different idea.
KC AUSTIN: It was a paradigm
shift for me to work in this.
I have a very like
game programming
mentality in Flash.
And I have the way that
I set things up
is completely different.
And Aubrey had to kind of turn
everything on its head for me.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PETE LEPAGE: So he had to apply
that 3D transform--
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah,
to your brain.
PETE LEPAGE: --and
then rotate.
KC AUSTIN: So I had to like
change things around
completely and get back into
that markup, CSS, JavaScript
kind of mentality.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So the next question, what kind
of DOM and JS cleanup did
you do to keep the performance
and memory leaks to a minimum?
As the user stays in
this experience,
like it runs 10 minutes.
KC AUSTIN: It has to clean
up everything.
You have to clean up
all the intervals.
And the Neutrino with like
setting display to none after
the pages are done.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah, we were
working within a framework
that we also invented
call Neutrino.
And what that does is just gives
you a simple lifestyle--
life cycle.
Also, some lifestyle management,
but mostly life
cycle management.
PETE LEPAGE: That would
be a pretty phenomenal
framework to have.
AUBREY ANDERSON: It comes
with a hat and some cool
sunglasses.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome,
sign me up.
AUBREY ANDERSON: It's a tool
that allows you to think in
terms of a kind of atomic
modular views.
And the views have a life cycle,
they become visible,
they become invisible.
And it just helps you manage
some of that stuff.
Our friend in this situation
is display none.
So what we found in browsers is
display none takes it out
of the memory stock.
So then you just have to be
careful about what JavaScript
is doing, make sure that
JavaScript is not running
away, or you don't have
an interval or a
timeout still running.
But by and large, if you are
animating with WebKit
animation for with transforms,
and you set display none on
any block of HTML, from there
all the way down the stack in
the DOM is just yanked.
And it's yanked actually
fairly quickly.
And you get the memory back
almost immediately.
So obviously each of these
scenes has hundreds and
hundreds of things going on.
They're massive, they're
transparent PNG files, they're
video files, and all
those things.
And so setting display none to a
whole block, we can actually
leave it in the DOM.
In some cases, we do, some
cases, we don't.
KC AUSTIN: Yeah, I was doing
some cleanup where on WebKit
end I would actually remove
the HTML element.
But that was more just
for me, so it wasn't
2,000 divs in the DOM.
AUBREY ANDERSON:
Yeah, totally.
The one exception, I
think, is video.
Obviously, even display
none on video,
it's a little squirrely.
So you'll see, if you watch
the life cycle in the DOM
happen, just let the thing play,
you'll see video tags
getting injected, they'll play,
they'll get pulled.
So we do try to do some more
aggressive cleanup and
management on video and
audio in particular.
But for animations and all that
stuff, it's just kind of
wonderfully managed by virtue
of the view state.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So we've only got like a
couple minutes left.
So I'm going to take
this last question.
I think it's a wonderful
question.
How would you recommend a web
developer that didn't do any
animations start using them
in their next app.
Is there a good framework
or library that
they should look at?
Or is there a set of tools?
How do they get started?
AUBREY ANDERSON: Well, I think
HTML5 Rocks is actually a
pretty nice place to start.
I'm not just plugging
a Google thing.
Like it actually is a nice place
to just step through an
approach to that.
KC AUSTIN: That's what I was
going through a lot when I
first started.
Just go through every one of
those things and just get
things moving around on screen,
very simple things,
and just build, just kind of
snowball up your tool box.
And go through each of the
functions, check all the
different timing functions,
durations, all
that kind of stuff.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah, you do
need to just jump into it,
make an animation,
and watch it go.
But it's not actually
that complicated.
So in some ways, it's something
that is noble and
easy to experiment with
and you can just do it
in HTML in a browser.
Just inline your CSS and
mess around with stuff.
And I'd start very simple.
Just make yourself a key frame
sequence with a 0% and 100%.
And just apply it and--
PETE LEPAGE: See what happens.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Yeah,
you'll sort of feel
your way through it.
It's like any new technology,
where there's a confused
couple of hours.
But it is actually really
well-documented, and
increasingly well-documented.
The first couple of years, it
was really, really hard to
find anything.
But I found, this year in
particular, a huge ramp up in
examples and copy, paste your
way through to something
happening, and just start
tweaking things, changing
variables, changing
time, and note.
And you'll go, oh, this is
a good way to do things.
It takes a minute to just change
your brain around from
thinking of there's a thing, I'm
going to select the thing,
and it's going to happen.
Largely we key animations to
class states, so you're still
selecting things sometimes
in the run time.
But a lot of times you're just
doing document.queryselector
some thing, and you're adding a
class to it or subtracting a
class to it.
PETE LEPAGE: All right,
well I want to
thank you guys so much.
We do have a case study
about building the 3D
world that's up.
We've got a bunch of other
case studies that we're
planning to put up over
the next couple weeks.
Because there's just so much
behind this whole experiment,
this whole world, that's
just like wow.
AUBREY ANDERSON: It sort of
leaks out of my ears.
PETE LEPAGE: Thank you
guys for joining us.
AUBREY ANDERSON: Thanks
for having us.
PETE LEPAGE: It's been really
great to have you and sort of
div in behind the divs here
and have a look at this.
Thank you guys for joining us.
And go check out Movi
Kanti Revo.
It's a M-O-V-I, Movi, Kanti,
K-A-N-T-I, Revo.
The URL is on screen.
Have a wonderful
day, everyone.
Thanks for joining us.
Bye bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]